we have received very disturbing reports
that Donald Trump was not even briefed
on the order he signed to put Steve
Bannon on the National Security Council
last week maybe even the week before I
told you that Donald Trump was making
some changes to the National Security
Council which is of course the major
entity that makes decisions about
foreign policy and national security
Donald Trump decided that the Joint
Chiefs of Staff the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff and the Director
of National Intelligence would only
sometimes attend the meetings of the
National Security Council and instead
I'll write propagandist and former
Goldman Sachs associate Steve Bannon
would have a regular seat on the
National Security Council committee
meetings we have now learned that Donald
Trump was not briefed about the
executive order he signed that made that
a reality according to the New York
Times this is so insane on so many
levels number one because it further
supports that Donald Trump is not really
in charge of or dictating what is going
on in the Trump administration something
we knew but there's another aspect of
this folks we've been covering now for
several days with viral results millions
of people interested in this story that
Donald Trump may not really know how to
read very well that he may be speaking
at a fourth grade level because he only
reads at a fourth grade level and that
idea is only supported by the reality
that Trump signed an order which changed
the structure of the National Security
Council without actually having read it
and this to me says it is even more
likely that Donald Trump can only barely
read you have a president making changes
to the top people charged with keeping
us safe this is no small thing this is
sort of according to the security mom
and similar types of voters this is kind
of the most important thing that the
president does and this report from the
New York Times tells us that the changes
were made by Trump without him even
being told nor having read what he was
signing on to incredibly disturbing I
finding it hard to even use words for
lack of a better term to explain the
seriousness of what is going on here
many of our viewers I know are very
concerned
it's been discussed on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash reddit i want to hear from you
about this it is hard for me to imagine
something more dangerous than the
president making decisions about our
national security without knowing what
those decisions are that he is just
signing his name on to